can I call you Gronk is that Alright uh
yeah that's cool but my you know my
close friends call me Rob
so but we're close friends man all right
you and I are close friends we take the
thing last year with Marshawn Lynch that
was so much fun just before the Super
Bowl we had a blast and afterwards
people were asking because I'm from
Boston everyone's like what's Gronk like
what's he like and I said he is the most
fun guy to hang around with just you
don't sweat things you enjoy life is
that true is that hard to say yes tend
to have liked to have a good time what
take me through your history here up
having a good time you're from Buffalo
New York
yes Buffalo New York and then you
decided to go to school at the U of
Arizona yes the University of Arizona
yeah my brother was getting recruited so
I took a recruiting visit with him to
Arizona when I was like a sophomore in
high school and I really liked the place
yeah I'm a lot yeah so I kind of went
back like the weather kept going there
back and back in I was just falling in
love with the place the weather I mean
the football team was good division one
football definitely top-of-the-line
football cod4 football for college and
you know the pool parties the ladies
kind of put that in the perspective too
because like I said I'd like to have a
good time and go out yeah yeah you do
you good and I think that's good and
good for you you in college you lived
with your brothers and you guys had kind
of a legendary house situation going on
at the University of Arizona is that
right yes tell us what was going on at
the house I mean after all the studying
was done and you know well what were you
what were you doing we tend to get our
schoolwork done first before out of a
party actually very good not like we all
know I want to get that out did the
school work first
but then the school works done the books
are away and then a seventh slide this
is what we live for
we were the slip and slide created
because we got home from an after party
my brother took their soap mister
started scoring it everywhere in the
house that's what people do when they
yeah you know he took the pop the faucet
off the fountain Derek started spraying
the water everywhere at people were like
what's going on what's he doing and the
next thing you know we started sliding
and was this one person decided just to
run full-speed jump on the ground and
just slide across we all thought it was
pretty cool we all just hop the end next
thing you know we were in our boxers
a bras and stuff our bras what do you
mean our broad my brother somehow always
wore like a piece of a woman's clothes
anyway you get ladies involved and then
it becomes this legendary thing where
you guys are men women underwears there
were rules right there were clothes or
the rules were you just had to run
full-speed and give it your best try
every time we like we just never let
anyone that's gonna do like a week week
trial go through our kitchen and get
slide like two feet yeah I was always
full go and it was while you always slip
out the back door if you had a good
slide so that was pretty dangerous too
you always have scraped up when you're
done buying a good night okay
Rob one question did you get your
security deposit back no you're done
renting that place was the guy who
rented it to you satisfied oh we
actually bought the place it's a museum
now I haven't go after my rookie year I
to go back and pay for all the damage oh
good okay you also had a build you
failed to rebuild the house there are
all these holes in the wall here in the
shape their own a shape of Cronk yeah
you got that right yeah the answer there
for me yeah yeah and a hot tub didn't
come with the house but you've you got a
hot tub so we wanted a hot so bad we
just knew it would go with us so we
literally took our bank accounts and
took everything out withdrawal all the
money I like ten bucks left for college
yeah my brother did we all come by spent
all your college money on the hot tub
yes we went there we went to store my
brother negotiated down there like $1500
so we could get this hot tub we finally
got it in the backyard and oh we need
some meat since on it even after like
the first week it was mad dirty like we
had like 20 people in it after one night
just it was just a blast but uh it was
just it was a great great investment
[Applause]